Heute im Rasenfunk?
Nein! Kylian Babbé! Ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, aber ich hab mich nur nicht satt gehört an diesem nahe neuen Intro der Liga Tour und erst recht nicht satt gehört hab ich mich an David Frogier de Ponlevoy von 3.90. Die Götter-Voter-Fans haben uns doch noch zusammenfinden lassen.
Oh ja, oh ja, oh ja. Ich hatte den ganzen Morgen kein Internet. Ich habe den Vorsprung noch gar nicht gehört. Ich bin tief beeindruckt.
Das ist die absolut richtige Emotion dazu. Und ein Morgen ohne Internet. Ich hätte hier schon mehrere Adern, die mir aus dem Gesicht herausquellen würden. Ich war nicht gerade glücklich. Aber es ist ja schön, dass wir unsere eigene kleine Liga-Tour machen. Heute Mittag ist schon diejenige erschienen zur Serie A, La Liga und Premier League. Wir sprechen jetzt noch kurz über die Liga. Bevor wir loslegen, aber der Hinweis, selbst diese kleine Minisendung hier ist crowdfinanziert. Das klappt. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann und schon kleine Beträge helfen. Auch wenn ihr nur die Liga-Tour bei uns hört, dann überlegt euch doch, welchen Wert das für euch hat. Es ist der eines kleinen Kaffees im Monat oder eines Kinobesuchs im Monat. Und überweist uns den dann bitte. Wir verteilen es auch brav weiter an unsere Gäste. So David, wir wollen blicken auf die Liga. Und da schaue ich mir die Tabelle an. Und da sehe ich, Moment mal, da grüßt mich doch Adi Hütter von der Spitze. Was ist denn da los? Was ist denn bei der AS Monaco los?
Ja, na, immerhin weißt du das. Na gut, das weißt du wahrscheinlich. Hat natürlich ja was mitbekommen, dass Adi Hütter zu Monaco ist. Ich setze noch mal kurz den Rahmen. Also wir erinnern uns noch, dass Nico Kovac vor einem Tabellen entlassen worden ist. Dann haben sie Philipp Clément gehabt. Der hat eigentlich richtig gut eingeschlagen am Anfang. Eine ganze, ganze Weile. Und das sah verdammt gut aus für Monaco. Ende der vergangenen Saison. Und dann hatten sie einen richtig beschissenen Saisonfinale. Die letzten sieben Spiele haben sie nur vier Punkte gemacht. Und sind aus den Top 3, wo sie die ganze Zeit waren, nochmal rausgepulstelt und spielen jetzt schon wieder nicht europäisch und zum fünften Jahr in Folge keine Champions League. Das ist schon krass für Monaco. Tatsächlich nicht der Anspruch, den sie haben. Und dann haben sie also gesagt, okay, dann brauchen wir doch jemand anderes und haben Adi Hütter geholt. Und Adi Hütter ist eingeschlagen bislang. Sie hatten ja auch den Sportdirektor gewechselt. Der Paul Mitchell ist auch gegangen. Der war ja auch recht erfolgreich und recht großer Name. Und mein Eindruck ist aber, sie haben extrem smart sich verstärkt über den Transfersommer. Es war vorher so ein bisschen die Angst, dass da ganz, ganz wichtige Spieler gehen könnten. Die Sazie ist ja gegangen, so für 45 Millionen zu Chelsea. Justo Fofana war ebenfalls im Gespräch. Der ist aber jetzt geblieben. Und eigentlich haben sie die Mannschaft von den wichtigen Spielern grob zusammengehalten.
Die haben Kevin Volland verloren.
Ja, der hat nicht mehr ganz so eine Rolle gespielt tatsächlich.
Also ist da niemand auf die Barrikaden gegangen. Keine brennende Mülltonne in Monaco.
Nein. Und dass Nübel gegangen ist, waren sie auch nicht so unglücklich tatsächlich. Und sie haben sich tatsächlich aber sehr, sehr schlau verstärkt in der Abwehr. Das war auch dringend nötig. Sie hatten glaube ich die 19 schlechteste Abwehr oder so von der Liga. Also von damals 20. Die Liga hat ja umgestellt, aber 18 Spiele, 18 Vereine dieses Jahr.
Ich sage es gerade schon richtig. Aber genau, das war ja zu diesem Jahr die Umstellung.
Genau. Von 18 Vereinen die 19 schlechteste Abwehr wäre ein bisschen blauabel gewesen. Und sie haben auch einen alten Bekannten wieder. Zachariah ist bei Monaco jetzt. Und ist richtig gut eingeschlagen tatsächlich so als defensiver Mittelfeldspieler. Und gefühlt haben sie auf allen Positionen jetzt Backups für ihre Leute. Und das scheint ihnen gut zu tun, so vom Konkurrenzkampf her. Sie spielen sehr athletisch. Da ist so ein bisschen die Frage, wie lange halten sie das durch? Aber andererseits haben sie keine Europa. Insofern, vielleicht können sie das auch gut durchhalten dann. Und ja, mit Hütter recht gradlinig, recht nach vorne, hohes Pressing, das kennt man. Aber das scheint ganz gut zu passen zu Monaco. Und ja, alles ganz in Ordnung.
Und was ja auch dazu führt, dass aktuell Paris schon mal zwei Punkte Rückstand hat. Also Monaco hat einmal unentschieden gespielt, ansonsten gewonnen. PSG hat zweimal unentschieden gespielt. Und vor allem die Torbilanz, 13 zu 5, das ist eigentlich die, die man für PSG erwartet, nach vier Spielen.
Also das ist absoluter Wahnsinn. Die haben richtig, richtig viele Tore geschossen. Hatten eigentlich noch so ein paar Klopper dabei, wo sie dann eine ganze Menge Tore kassiert haben. 4 zu 2 gegen Clermont. Das ist jetzt auch kein großer Verein. 3 zu 3 gegen Nantes. Aber haben auch zweimal zu Null gespielt, dann eben gegen Straßburg und Lens jetzt. Das ist schon in Ordnung. Sie haben ein bisschen das Problem, dass sie eigentlich relativ wenige Stürmer haben. Embolo ist verletzt. Der hat einen Kreuzbandriss. Der kommt erst im Frühling wieder. Das heißt, sie haben eigentlich nominell nur Ben Yader. Ben Yader war in der Vorbereitung noch komplett torlos. Hat aber jetzt groß aufgedreht zum Saisonstart. Und sie haben diese letzte Lücke noch geschlossen mit dem Stürmer, in dem sie einen Mann geholt haben, den wir auch schon mal gesprochen haben hier im Rasenfunk, Balogun, der bei RAS gespielt hat, der von Arsenal kam, der zu Arsenal zurückgegangen ist, war ja eine Laie, und jetzt aber nach Monaco gegangen ist. Es ist zu vermuten, dass Hütter jetzt sein System nicht unbedingt umstellt und auf zwei Stürmer umstellt, sondern dass sie Balogun sogar eher als Ersatz nehmen für Ben Yader, dessen Vertrag läuft nächstes Jahr aus. Also eher jemand, bei dem sie auf die Zukunft setzen. Der kam jetzt gegen Los rein in den letzten Schlussminuten. Da konnten wir jetzt aber nicht so viel daraus ableiten, weil da haben sie schon deutlich geführt. Da haben sie dann eher auf Konter gespielt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt künftig so sein wird, dass sie mit Balogunern irgendwie das System ändern. Muss man sehen.
Und wie wird Adi Hütter aufgenommen, um seine Art Fußball zu spielen? Es klingt ehrlich gesagt relativ ähnlich zu dem, was wir bei Eintracht Frankfurt und auch bei Borussia Mönchengladbach gesehen haben. Kommt das gut an?
Ja, witzig war, dass direkt der erste Artikel, den ich wahrgenommen habe, als Hütter gemeldet wurde, war erstmal, was bedeutet dieser Vorname? Wo kommt der her? Was bedeutet das? Und ansonsten, ehrlich gesagt, ist sein Stil gar nicht so unterschiedlich von Clément. Er ist noch mal ein bisschen geradliniger, noch mal ein bisschen höher verteidigt, aber das passt schon. Auch das ist kein ganz dummer Transfer von den Verantwortlichen von Marco. Da passt der Kader, wie gesagt, auch schon ganz gut dazu. Er hat einen großen Stürmer, der auch mal mit dem Rücken zum Tor spielen kam, hat schnelle Leute, er hat mit dem Brazilianer auf den Außen, Außenverteidiger Kajoyen, Rekon Wandersen, Leute, die schnell und ausdauernd sind. Das ist schon ein sehr, sehr druckvolles, kraftvolles Mittelfeld mit Kamara und Fafana. Und wem er wiederbelebt hat, ist Minamoto. Der war damals aus Liverpool gekommen und galt schon ein bisschen als Flop, weil er aus Liverpool gekommen ist, und dann aber relativ wenig einsetzte. Hütter kannte ihn aber von seiner Zeit in Salzburg noch. Er wusste, wie er ihn einsetzt. Er hat da direkt... Ich würde es aus der Rückschau interpretieren. Aber er hat ihn so eingesetzt, dass er jetzt richtig zieht. Er bietet sich schlau an, hat die meisten Zworapunkten, zieht Lücken in der Rückwärtsbewegung. Das hat alles Hand und Fuß. Da greift er sehr viel zusammen.
Das klingt sehr gut. Minaminu, du hattest Minamoto gesagt, für alle, die hinterhergekugelt haben. Ich war mich auch verwirrt. Den kenne ich nicht. Aber ich habe ihn noch entdeckt. Das sind alles sehr positive Nachrichten. Aber es ist nicht nur alles gut gerade bei Monaco. Ein Thema von neben dem Platz. Gibt es noch, was wir kurz erwähnen wollen?
Genau, es gibt ein Thema neben dem Platz. Das passt sogar ein bisschen zu dem, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Wir hatten Benyader angesprochen. Seit August ist er unter Investigation für Sexvernütigung und versucht zu Vergewaltigung. Da soll es einen Fall gegeben haben. Nach einem der ersten Trainings von Hütter ist er an die Côte d'Azur, also aus Monaco, rausgereist, hat am Strand zusammen mit seinem Bruder zwei junge Frauen getroffen, hat mit denen eine Nacht im Airbnb verbracht. Danach haben diese Frauen sich bei der Polizei gemeldet und haben den Männern Nötigung vorgeworfen. Ich bin mir gar nicht ganz sicher, ob das eine Versuchte oder Schrägstechvergewaltigung war. Der Staatsanwalt hat Ermittlungen aufgenommen. Die waren sogar zwei Tage untersuchungshaft. Sie sind aber erst mal auf Koalitionen freigekommen. Der Verein ist da aktuell sehr schmal lippig und sagt, die Behörden machen jetzt ihre Arbeit und wir warten ab. Tatsächlich ist das auch alles, was ich dazu sagen kann. Also, wenn jeder mal Probleme mit der spanischen Steuer hatte, aber das ist ja nur eine ganz andere Art von Delikt. Wichtig ist er auf jeden Fall für Monaco.
Ist er nicht sogar Kapitän auch?
Also, es ist kein Wunder, dass der Verein da vermutlich jetzt ungern Unruhe reinbringt oder mal im Vorfeld sagt, wegen den Gerüchten setzen wir dich aus. Das werden sie sich schwer leisten können.
Dann warten wir ab, was da die Ermittlungen ergeben und wie es jetzt dann weitergeht vor Monaco. Natürlich ist das erst mal nur eine Momentaufnahme, aber eine sehr positive. Du hast es ja vor allem in den richtigen Kontext gesetzt, gerade nach diesem Saisonfinish, jetzt so in die neue Saison zu starten. Das lohnt sich definitiv.
Genau, die Medienberichte sind schon so ein bisschen wie bei uns Richtung Leverkusen, nach dem Motto, endlich mal vielleicht der einzige Verein in der Liga, der aktuell den Bayern, PSG stoppen kann.
Ja gut, das ist dann vielleicht noch ein bisschen früh.
Ist vielleicht ein bisschen früh, genau.
Vielleicht, vielleicht. Die Frage ist, wie früh ist es dann zu sagen, Olympique Lyon steigt sicher ab?
Ja, also wir springen von ganz oben nach ganz unten. Und das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen ein Drama. Also, weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich bin ja noch aus der Generation bei der Lyon, der Serienmeister der 2000er Jahre war. Und da ist ein bisschen eine Ära tatsächlich zu Ende gegangen im vergangenen Jahr, weil ja auch der Präsident, Jean-Michel Olaß, der maßgeblich verantwortlich war für diesen unglaublichen Aufstieg seit den 80ern, der ja auch so ein bisschen dieses ganze Business Modell und alles reingebracht hat in den Fußball, der wirklich eine sehr prägende Figur war. Der hat seine Anteile verkauft. Da kam ein amerikanischer Investor rein, John Textor, dem ein wahres Fußball-Empirium gehört. Molenbeek in Belgien, Crystal Palace in England, Botafogo in Brasilien. Und der hatte eigentlich gesagt, der lässt Olaß noch als Präsident gewähren, hat ihn aber dann rausgeschmissen, entfernt, vergangenes Jahr. Dann hat er den Trainer gewechselt. Ja, also alles hat gewechselt quasi. Also Besitzer hat gewechselt, Präsident hat gewechselt zur Halle Umwälzung. Und jetzt, gerade eben wurde auch Laurent Blanc eben noch entlassen diese Woche als Trainer. Und das war tatsächlich ein, also das war alles ziemlich katastrophal. Da ist alles ein bisschen, wirkt groß wie ein Hühnerhaufen. Sie haben keine alsingesehene Sieg in der Vorbereitung gehabt. Am vierten Spieltag den Trainer zu entlassen, ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so unbedingt die allerbeste Situation. Hätte man sich auch vorher überlegen können. Blanc war schon im vergangenen Jahr, ging so, aber dann haben sie in der Rückrunde richtig die Kurve bekommen, war ein drittbester Rückrundentabelle. Also hat das ihm so ein bisschen den Kopf gerettet. Aber sie haben, also sie hatten schon im vergangenen Jahr Schwierigkeiten, teilweise mit defensiven Mannschaften. Und sie hatten so ein paar Lichtblicke. Scherky ist eine wirklich gute Nummer 10. Und dann hatten sie einen Jungen, den Durchbruch des vergangenen Jahres, Bakula. Und tolle Entscheidungen, starke Vorlagen und all das. Und die haben sie jetzt verkauft zu PSG, weil sie Geld brauchen. Kommen wir vielleicht noch gleich dazu, warum sie Geld brauchen. Also sie haben Bakula und Luckeba, bekanntlich zu Leipzig, haben da ihre Punkstücke verkauft und haben dafür, naja, also erstmal Leute eingekauft, von denen sich noch niemand so richtig durchgesetzt hat.
Also ich kenne keinen von denen. Ich gucke mir gerade die Neuzugänge an. Ich kenne keinen. Aber ich sehe auch, man hat eine Transferseite von rund 80 Millionen hat man eingenommen, also durch die Verkäufe.
Genau. Ja, Kaleta Cha kennt man von Southampton, zumindest in der Liga. Der hat bei Marseille gespielt, war aber auch schon so ein bisschen Licht und Schatten da. Ja, also sie haben eine Mannschaft, die eh schon nicht ganz so ideal war, noch stärker geschwächt. Und Laurent Blanc hat immer wieder gesagt, was er braucht, ist nur noch 6. Also er braucht eigentlich einen starken 6er. Den wollte er haben, den hat er aber nicht. Die Holding Six. Was heißt das auf Französisch? Saint-Henel, ein Wächter. Und eine kleine Anekdote an der Stelle ist, während Lyon immer hektisch noch seine Nummer 6 gesucht hat und gleichzeitig einen Ersatz für Bacula braucht, hat Atexto mit PSG verhandelt. Aber nicht für Lyon, sondern damit er Ikitike zu Crystal Palace holen kann. Das sind die kleinen Problemchen, die auftauchen, wenn ein Mensch mehrere Clubs besitzt. Was ja auch bis nach Deutschland gedrungen ist, war die eine Meldung, dass dieser Spieler in Belgien für eine Rekordsumme verpflichtet worden ist, aber direkt weiterverliehen wurde von ihm. Da steckt er ja auch mit seinem Imperium dahinter.
Um eben gewisse Financial Fairplay-Regelungen zu umgehen. Und so ist es sportlich, das haben wir jetzt noch gar nicht gesagt, zweimal 1 zu 4 verloren, einmal 1 zu 2 und dann noch 0 zu 0. Das heißt, erst ein Punkt nach vier Spielen und deswegen auch eben sehr deutlich dieser letzte Platz.
Genau und dieses Spiel gegen PSG war auch ein Klassensunterschied tatsächlich.
Bis zur Halbzeit stand schon 0-4, oder?
Ja, also es war nicht nur ein Klassensunterschied, es waren drei Klassensunterschiede. Und die Fans waren extrem, extrem sauer. Da gab es auch ein paar kleine Videos, die auf Social Media kursiert sind. Es gab auch Spruchbänder gegen Bacola und Lokeba, dass man seinen Ausbildungsverein nicht im Sturm verlässt. Da waren sie auch wütend. Anschließend ging der Capo auf den Zaun und hat den Spielern kräftig die Meinung gesagt, dass sie da ein Shirt tragen, das Traditionen und dass dafür dieses Shirt Leute sehr viel Schweiß reingehauen haben. Und dass die aktuellen Spieler eine Schande sind und so weiter und so weiter. Da ist sehr, sehr viel Unruhe auf allen Fronten.
Und woher kommt das jetzt, dass man Lokeba und Bacola verkaufen musste, um Geld einzunehmen?
Weil sie von der französischen Finanzaufsicht, der berühmten DNCG, diese Auflage bekommen haben. Das hat unter anderem zu tun mit dieser ganzen Übernahme von Textor, der da sehr viel Geld investiert hat und im Vorfeld schon verpflichtet war, eigentlich noch weitere Aktien zu kaufen, also von kleinen Anlegern. Da ist er aber dann im Verzug gewesen. Das hätte er im Februar schon machen sollen, hat im Mai das noch nicht getan. Und im Juli hatte die DNCG dann gemahnt, also der muss jetzt noch dem Verein frisches Geld zuschießen, weil sein Businessplan, den er da bei der Übernahme vorgelegt hat, der ist gerade so aktuell nicht haltbar. Der Businessplan sah vor, dass Lyon Champions League spielt. Und TechStore wirft dann Olaß vor jetzt, dass er ihn belogen hat über die Finanzen. Also das hätte er ja gar nicht gewusst, alles und so weiter. Und wenn ich das gewusst hätte, hätte ich das so nicht gekauft. Und Olaß sagt, ich hatte aber einen ganz anderen, also ich hatte einen ganz anderen Businessplan als du. Tatsächlich würde ich eher vermuten, dass da vielleicht ein, also das ist jetzt Spekulation, aber dass möglicherweise ein amerikanischer Geschäftsmann da nicht ganz mit den französischen Gepflogenheiten und was da so die Finanzaufsicht und alles so macht und durchdrückt und wovor sie Respekt und wovor nicht, dass er das damit nicht gerechnet hat. Es startete auch ziemlich viel im Chaos tatsächlich. Also es war alles sehr unvorbereitet. Wer übernimmt da jetzt die sportliche Leitung? Wer ist jetzt Präsident? Wie gesagt, dann hat Texter Olaß entlassen und ist dann selbst Präsident geworden. Und Ende vom Lied ist jetzt, sie sind unter dem Zwang, waren unter dem Zwang, Spieler abzugeben. Und die Ponte ist jetzt, dass Olaß dann jetzt noch gesagt hat, naja, also Texter hat mich wiederum betrogen. Der hat gesagt, er zahlt mir für meine Aktien Geld. Das hat er aber noch nicht getan. Und deswegen blockiere ich jetzt Konten von Lyon, auf die ich noch Zugriff habe, weil mir diese 15 Millionen Euro, oder was es sind, die hat er mir nicht gezahlt. Also friere ich die jetzt ein. Was dann L'équipe nach dem Sieg von PSG zu der wunderschönen Überschrift verleitet hat, PSG friert Lyon ein. Ja, also da ist ein richtiger Streit im Hintergrund, wie man es sich nicht chaotischer vorstellen kann.
Investoren machen einfach immer alles besser. Und immerhin gibt es Geld, das man einfrieren kann. Es ist wenigstens keine Glasbintost-Oma.
Die Geschichte, dass ein sehr langjähriger Präsident, der dann offiziell weg ist, es dann auch noch nicht ganz so loslassen kann, ist ja jetzt auch nicht so ganz unbekannt vielleicht.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, auf wen du da anspielst, aber mir juckt die Schulter. Ich habe so ein neues Tattoo bekommen. Falls ihr das gesehen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, sensationell. Also, das sind die Situationen bei Monaco und Lyon. Vier Spieltage sind gespielt und die einen sind ganz oben und die anderen ganz unten. Dann lass uns doch noch kurz zu den Awards kommen, die du vergeben kannst, so für diese erste Phase der Saison. Wer war denn dein MVP?
Mein MVP ist Dante. Der wird nächsten Monat 40 Jahre alt. Der wird nächsten Monat 40 Jahre alt. Das ist unglaublich.
Einer der wenigen Fußballspieler, der noch älter ist als ich. Möge er immer weiterspielen.
Der war jetzt beim Sieg von Nizza gegen Straßburg. Im ersten Sieg von Nizza in der Saison war er sehr wichtig für die Abwehr. Er hat über 130 Ballkontakte und die Vorlage fürs 1-0 gegeben.
Wer ist dann der Unsung Hero, wenn schon der MVP Dante ist?
Unsung Hero wäre für mich Kuziayev. Das ist ein russischer Mittelfeldspieler in Diensten von Aufsteigern Leavre. Die haben Lurian 13.0 abgefertigt und haben damit für einen Aufsteiger einen ziemlich guten Start hingelegt. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob ich hier richtig ausspreche. Er hat bislang nur in Russland gespielt, kam jetzt mit 30 Jahren in die Ligue 1 rüber, ist Nationalspieler, lange Karriere bei Zenit, St. Petersburg. Das war auch schon ein kleiner Coup, das Leavre den verpflichtet hat. Das ist aber extrem wichtig für den Aufsteiger, was Balleroberung, Spielübersicht angeht. Es gab eine kleine Anekdote, hat ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten in der Kabine, weil, wie der Torwart gesagt hat, der spricht schon ziemlich gut Englisch. Aber wir sprechen halt kein Englisch in der Kabine. Das wusste ich leider auch schon sehr. Aber auch da, also Leavre mit einem ganz akzeptablen Start, Aufsteiger Metz übrigens auch mit einem akzeptablen Start, der Abstiegskampf könnte spannend werden. Oh ja, das stimmt.
Ich meine, diesmal sind es ja wieder nur zwei klare Absteiger und ein Relegationsteilnehmer. Letztes Jahr war es dieses Race to the Bottom mit den vier Absteigern. Also ein bisschen zivilisierter wird es, aber ja.
Und Lyon steht ja schon fest, haben wir gesagt, insofern...
Im, also jetzt sind es ja nur noch zwei. Ja, außer sie holen sich Felix Maggert. Ich habe gehört, der hat dringenden Bedarf, noch mal irgendeinen Verein zu retten. Und beim Verband darf er, glaube ich, nicht ran, nach dem, was ich gehört habe.
Ja, also aktuell ist Fabio Grosso im Gespräch, habe ich gehört.
Als Trainer kann ich ihn nicht bewerten, aber viele positive Erinnerungen an ihn als Spieler. Guter Mann. Ja, David, das war doch ein schöner kurzer Blick auf die Liga. Das nächste Mal würde ich sagen, machen wir das wieder in größerer Runde.
Ja, ich hoffe, ja.
Gibt es noch Matches to Watch an diesem Wochenende? Das habe ich noch vergessen zu fragen.
Ich habe mal reingeschaut, also im Grunde, was in Deutschland übertragen wird. Auf Dutzen kann man sich alles anschauen. Paris-Nitze geht es morgen los. Klingt ja für mich als Radsport feiern eher wie ein Radrennen. Genau. Dann rennen Lille, auf jeden Fall sicherlich auch. Und, was wir gerade schon gesprochen haben, Lorient Monaco am Sonntag um eins.
Na, dann ist ja das Wochenende schon durchgeplant.
Was man sich leider nicht anschauen kann, ist Lyon gegen Le Havre, wo wir schon da waren. Das wäre jetzt aber gut.
Man kann nicht alles haben, aber man kann David Frogier de Ponlevoy in der Liga Tour haben. Und da bin ich dir sehr dankbar für. Danke dir, dass du dir jetzt spät abends noch die Zeit genommen hast, dieses Segment nachzuholen. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Das war unsere Kurzausgabe in der nächsten Woche. Übrigens gibt es hier in der Liga Tour eine Sendung zur zweiten Bundesliga der Männer in Deutschland. Und am Wochenende wird natürlich auch wieder Bundesliga der Männer besprochen. Und es geht ja auch los bei den Frauen in der Bundesliga. Also, ich glaube, in den nächsten fünf Tagen, vier oder fünf Sendungen, na ja, abonniert einfach alle Feeds, dann verpasst ihr nichts. Und ich werde einfach nie wieder schlafen. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!